good morning one eight six seven ah good
morning doctor
wonderful to see you come in come in
have yourself a seat now if I remember
correctly the last time you were here I
was telling you about the time I was
captured by the you Bala tribe of the
Congo actually I had some questions
about your story you see no such tribe
exists of course not
there weren't any of the you Bala left
after the village was attacked by the
mikkel a member I still regret not being
able to bag that monster when I had the
chance
it is a persistent play elusive creature
one eight six seven we have no actual
proof that what you're saying is not
just an elaborate fiction the artifacts
and records we found in your vault could
easily be fakes nonsense
I would never fabricate any of my work
why it's against the very heart of being
a naturalist while I'm repeatedly amazed
by your institution here you seem to be
missing the Explorer spirit when I
scaled the Himalayas in search of the
monks of the golden mountain did I worry
about what others had said about them of
course not I went and found out for
myself you do realize you're a sea slug
right
good heavens boy have you been drinking
that's utterly ridiculous if you can't
be bothered to be sensible then I have
no reason to speak with you go get
yourself a nice cup of tea and sober up
hi there volgin here would you like to
request another SCP article receive live
updates posted straight to your computer
device then call the volgen on Oh 8
hundred facebook-dot-com forward-slash
the Volgin that's Oh 8 hundred
facebook-dot-com forward-slash the
volgen call now time to additions apply
well protected calls may be recorded or
mounted for training books in smoke I
just necessary seems to offer details go
home may be at risk of you know keep up
intend this once may go up as well as
down may cause pains nausea vomiting
and/or convulsions if he's possessed
this inside your doctor always read the
label written identity may be required
but organ is regulated by the savings
and investment authority thank you